Imagine that you've just been hired as
director of clinical operations at a brand new
company in Silicon Valley. A promising new drug
has been shown to be very effective at
reducing the risk of prostate cancer in mice.
But preclinical animal studies also showed that some
mice had a mutation in a gene that
caused adverse side effects. Now, the mice that
didn't have this particular mutation, didn't have the
side effects either. Now you're going to begin to design
your clinical trial to test this in humans
and you discover that this gene is conserved from
mice to humans and that's like 90% identitcal.
And about 3% of humans have the same mutation
that caused the really adverse side effects in
mice. So which of the following do you think
would be the most ethical decision to design your
clinical trial, and why? Would you include those humans with
the adverse side effect mutation to have a more scientific
conclusion? Or since you can identify them using their genetic
information would you not include those individuals with the
adverse side effect mutation so that. They don't have to
suffer the consequences. I want you to pick one of
these answers and tell me why in the box here.